tucker you ready to laugh yeah i know
you think you're the funniest person in
the room but i'm here today and so is
this video so we're gonna have to
reevaluate
no i told you it's the funniest thing in
the room why why were they doing just
okay it says in this week's episode of
mythbusters yeah so they're like testing
to see if it's true to see if
why does the beginning say when baby
wakes up from the three hours because
they're like doing the thing that you do
when you just like wake like this is
like
babies yes so they're treating him like
a baby
now
is that actually how they had him
yeah
i'm so curious why they made a statue of
this man going like this is that jesus
christ
it doesn't look like they're in a church
why is jesus throwing up the jesus like
this
[Laughter]
shout out
shout out to jesus
do you want a little coke
[Music]
if not we have pepsi also
[Laughter]
like as soon as you see the little bag
you're like whoa and then it's like
this one right here he's like holding it
if not
he has options that's that's what we
love and then if he has fanta orange i
am down and i'm like how did you get
this in like why is it with this little
clip like why do you have so many i did
like hold on flags i think like you know
when they're really they have the real
drugs uh they have them in like a little
clip not that i've done that because i'm
just assuming that's what he's doing
i am the most boring raper ever i'm so
straight edge i'm not even joking
i know you think you're the funniest
person in the room but
i am
but uh actually i'm in the room and so
is this video so let's do it
i'll be honest i shop at zara and this
one's now on my list to go too i like
that that was good that was good content
not the funniest person in the room
content because i'm here but good
content sure sure yeah of course well do
you get why it's funny it's because it's
to the tune of bad romance
you think that i didn't grow up
listening to lady gaga's bad romance at
13 years old thinking i had been through
the heartbreak that she had been through
obviously i understood the tune did you
think you had been through the
heartbreak that you'd been through at 13
years old who hasn't come on
i guess it's not that funny no it's it's
great content but just not as funny as
us that's true what can you do this is
me
i'm taking all of my belongings oh my
god so wait so wait i needed processes
he is moving in to his cubicle at work
yes
how
he's just doing it this is like
he's putting up a protest so his name is
simon and he is protesting how much he
gets paid versus how much his rent is so
he decided to move into his office oh my
god i mean hey first his cubicle was
large it's probably like a studio here
in l.a
or new york so that's that's an upgrade
my thing is why is he shirtless
this is his house now he lives there
look at him moving in he put his light
in he has on his pajama pants no shirt
his his
i he's the one singing too yeah that's
his background music yeah yeah and he
kept his followers updated and
eventually he got evicted
he got kicked out there
[Applause]
yes thanks so much for watching uh if
you have any other videos you want us to
react to drop them in the comments uh
we'll see you guys next time yeah we
will
[Applause]
[Music]